bonsoir philippe laurent merci d'être
avec nous alors vous êtes signataires
d'une tribune publiée dans médiapart
nous voulons plus être gouvernés par la
peur
35 chercheurs universitaires et médecins
dont vous critiquent la communication du
gouvernement sur la crise du coc vite
qu'il juge trop anxiogène pour quelles
raisons expliquées et nous alors moi
j'étais assez interpellé par cette
tribune parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un problème tant que médecin généraliste
auxquelles je suis confronté tous les
jours c'est l'angoissé des patients et
c'est réellement un problème difficile
parce qu'on sent que les gens sont
extrêmement touchées extrêmement anxieux
on n'a pas une consultation sans qu'on
soit amené à être amené à traiter ce
sujet et on sent vraiment une des gens
désemparés
une communication qui qui donne
l'impression de ne pas trop savoir où on
va et donc on a vraiment l'impression
que les patients sont complètement dans
le dos tu m'étonnes qui peut en en
question tout ce qu'on peut leur
raconter vu toutes les différentes
propositions qui seront faites donc
c'est vrai que c'est pour moi quelque
chose d'extrêmement difficile quelque
chose de quotidien que j'affronte tous
les jours donc c'est vrai quand j'ai vu
cette tribune j'ai trouvé que ça faisait
un grand écho il ça fait beaucoup de
sens donc c'est pour ça que j'ai signé
j'ai signé ses deux plus voilà vous vous
dites voilà on entend bien la langue c
était des patients vous décrivez mais ce
que c'est c'est vraiment la faute du
gouvernement je me fais l'avocat du
diable c'est la communication du
gouvernement qui est trop anxiogène
on s'est tout simplement le virus mais
même je ne ferai pas le raccourci comme
celui de vous faites géré en disant que
c'est la faute du gouvernement
je dirais que c'est un faux pas c'était
une question jeudi a juste pas que c'est
la faute de la communication générale
actuelle qui est extrêmement anxiogènes
donc la communication donc pardo pas
parler donc les le gouvernement c'est
une chose mais la coupe de la
communication par un certain nombre de
médias c'est vrai que ça
retient une anxiété ces entretiens un
stress et en fait on n'est plus dans un
sentiment de peur et ce sentiment de
peur je pense est extrêmement délétère
pour pouvoir réagir plus favorablement
plus positivement pour essayer d'avoir
une prise de conscience meilleure par
rapport à ce qu'il faut faire pour
pouvoir affronter ce virus parce que je
vais pas remettre en doute et en
question en effet le fait qu'on a des
taux qui augmente vous avez vu sur
marseille le préfet a dit qu'il y avait
des taux à 10 6 2 fin de positivité nous
ici sur la région dans le var en à des
taux donc puisqu'on a des études qui
sont fait tacler laboratoire avec
lesquels on travaille donc nous sommes
localement nous allécher qui ont de 3 8
à 5 2% de tests positifs donc c'est vrai
qu'à une augmentation des positive piqué
mais des tests positifs les malades vous
avez évoqué le dernier chic de santé
font depuis de données par santé
publique france ce soir donc plus plus
quatre 148 carrière sur les sept
derniers jours ce qui t'a liseret en réa
et de 34 morts dont 24 heures donc c'est
sûr que tout ça on ne peut pas le mettre
en question moi ce qui me matter roche
c'est pourquoi cette peur entretenue
pourquoi toute cette anxiété entretenu
et c'est plus là où je me pose des
questions en tant que médecin et dans le
temps qu'eux aussi citoyen justement en
tant que médecin c'est très important ce
que l'on ne dit pas ce que vous touchez
au coeur d'un problème vous venez nous
dire voilà je ne nie pas les chiffres
mais sont-ils si importants que ça d'un
point de vue du médecin on va pas voilà
reparler des chiffres du cancer des
morts sur la route etc etc
est ce qu'aujourd'hui cette peur selon
vous est ce qu'elle est quand même en
corrélation avec une situation réelle ou
pas tellement finalement une situation
réelle de pandémie afin d' évolution et
de circulation du virus
ça c'est une réalité simplement c'est le
mode de communication il ya trois mois
on vous annonçait des chiffres de morts
et de patience totalisant réanimation
aujourd'hui on nous annonce et qui fait
surtout écho qui résonne sont le chiffre
de cas positifs donc tous les jours on
nous annonce joue
orbite par exemple 7158 cas positifs en
plus donc en fait les cas positifs ça
veut dire ça veut pas forcément dire des
gens malades
enfin moi dans mon exercice quotidien
qui certainement pas significatif mais
bon qui est mien je vois j'ai vu des cas
positifs sur en particulier c'est des
sujets jeunes qui vont qui vont plutôt
bien enfin qu'ils sont peu très très peu
symptomatiques
donc il faut je pense aussi garder un
peu sa raison garder et puis voir un
petit peu ce qui sera intéressant c'est
de savoir sur ces câbles positif en fait
tu es l'état clinique des patients et
c'est ça qui est important que pouvoir
avoir une idée et puis c'est surtout
voir le nombre de morts est comme assez
significatif on est à 34 morts donc
aujourd'hui donc c'est il n'y a pas
d'explosion comme on avait à l'époque
deux à l'époque mars avril
alors bien sûr c'est qu'elle touche
aussi qui est extrêmement fluctuants qui
quasiment évolue de jour en jour donc
c'est vrai que notre attitude doit
s'adapter à toutes les tout ce qu'on
peut constater mais je crois qu'il faut
aussi garder un petit peu de raison un
petit peu de sang froid par rapport à
tout ça donc moi je vois des gens qui me
disent ne plus sortir de tout chez eux
tellement ils sont angoissés et stressé
des gens qui sont vraiment cloîtrés chez
eux dans le traumatisme docteur de
justement ce qui s'est passé il ya cinq
mois
ces images difficiles la télévision les
hôpitaux surchargés ce qui s'est passé
dans le grand test est ce qu'on n'est
pas finalement dans le traumatisme de
cela et on veut à tout prix éviter aussi
et un recond finement j'entends bien je
comprends mais est ce que la peur est le
meilleur conseiller pour ça parce que la
peur est la meilleure façon pour qu'on
d'éveil de conscience sur la nécessité
des gestes barrières sur le jeu je
m'interroge est-ce que c'est la peur qui
va nous permettre de réagir mieux ou est
ce que c'est la peur qui peut au
contraire nous amener à des réactions
plus de 2 qui vante regarder ce qui se
passe avec les pros masquer les antilles
masque on est dans une société qui est
déjà fragile qui est en train de se
priver par rapport à ces questions donc
ça s'interroge beaucoup sur nos
comportements sur comment ont réagi par
rapport à cette situation qui est
difficile
donc moi je
beaucoup de questions même si j'ai mal
en terre pardonnez moi vous vous coupez
mais mais on sait dans la lignée de ce
qu'on se pose comme question ce nouveau
clip à la télévision quand on voit la
jeune embrasser sa grand-mère qui
convoie à la fin se retrouver en
réanimation ça rappelle un petit peu les
images de la sécurité routière on
imagine que d'après ce que vous nous
dites vous voilà vous n'êtes pas en
accord avec ce genre de communication en
accord avec ce genre de communication
qui comme quelque chose de c'est déjà la
situation est assez compliqué les gens
je pense sont assez stressés
je pense que dans les effets collatéraux
de cette de cet épisode sanitaire il y
aura tous les problèmes de gestion du
stress les problèmes de là je pense que
c'est une réalité qu'on n'a pas encore
toutes les conséquences et c'est vrai
que ce clip
bon je pense qu'il faut éveiller les
consciences à la nécessité des gestes
barrière se laver les mains de fin de
garde et la distanciation social ça
c'est fondamental ça ça peut pas se
remettre en question mais de là à
envoyer des images aussi fin violente
parce que moi j'ai trouvé ça que l'on
sait non je sais quelque chose qui
rajoute à la peur et à l' angoisse
merci beaucoup en tout cas philippe
leroy je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france